we're just seeing their lies knocked
down one at a time it's like watching
the dominoes fall one lie goes into
another goes into another goes into
another and then people start realizing
look if you're on martha's vineyard
right now there's a video going around
of a woman who's just a resident there
you know basically saying we don't have
the infrastructure we can't do anything
about this and it's like maybe she's
about to be red-pilled maybe she's
suddenly gonna realize boy i'm not
better than those people that live in
the border towns in texas in california
and arizona and everything else well
then of course you guys probably saw
that earlier in the week kamala harris
did do an interview where she said that
the border is secure uh then of course
this whole thing happens and she got
asked if that's actually the case
vice president here is any comment on
the migrants that were dropped off at
the naval observatory
[Applause]
no no laughing that time yeah viva she's
she's better when she's not talking huh
they can't keep up with their own
rubbish you saw jean-pierre you know
trying to answer a question uh they
can't keep up with their own lies they
can't keep up with the false that people
are seeing in real time just to get back
to something about gavin newsom dave
gavin newsom suggesting they investigate
desantis for busting migrants to
martha's vineyard as though that's a
federal crime uh be careful what you
asked for because i seem to recall joe
biden flying underage children uh into
the middle of new york in the dead of
night although this might be gavin's uh
long-term play to get desantis and potus
so that he can be the next potus but
they don't think two steps ahead in
terms of consequences of policies and
i'm saying the political left here open
borders but we're not migrant towns so
so long as it stays in someone else's
backyard okay oh now it's now it's in
our backyard well we don't think we
should use people for political pool to
tools but let's use them for virtue
signaling points online oh let's go
investigate people for for transporting
migrants maybe think that in about one
step that's gonna backfire on you
because that's what's been going on for
a long time
uh but
social media is a toxic hellhole but
it's also a very useful place to share
the madness share the insanity and share
the information i know i hate it so much
and i'm trying to use twitter less but
the last day or so on there it's the
memes have been great it's like we're
watching you know who knows where
they're where they're you know siphoning
us and and whether people are actually
seeing what we're sharing and all that
kind of stuff but there's been a lot of
fun stuff out there because it's like
man the truth if you can get the truth
out there clearly and cleanly it is fun